I'm so not right for this role I can't
do this I've instantly got filled with
fear doubt everything I literally put my
hand on the door and I twist the knob
and I'm turning to go and the casting
director goes Troy I think about that
moment a lot I would still be watching
it I would still be playing it but I
would definitely be on the outside and
not where I am right now
you trust me
oh
the man Troy Baker himself is here Troy
how you doing man I was halfway about to
get up from my seat when you said there
was like they had the wrong person not
the most epic oh my God who is it I am
beyond excited to be here thank you guys
for having me obvious we're gonna talk
about the things that I'm most excited
to talk about in my life how do you
describe the last
we Neil druckman who's of course uh one
of the creators he's a naughty dog the
studio that put the game out in 2013 and
is now one of the showrunners for the
show this incredible truly remarkable
show on HBO
um has just coined the best phrase and
it's the most simple cliche right word
but it's it's surreal I had this one
moment when we were shooting my episode
and I'm on set in this beautiful very
cold location and we're sitting there
and we're getting you know cameras set
up and everything and we're about to
roll on our first shot and I'm by this
beautiful River and it's cold and I just
chuckled and the person next to you goes
what are you laughing about it's a very
serious scene we're about to do is like
if you could go back
12 years
to the version of me that walked into
that audition on that sound stage and go
just to let you know
this is going to be the biggest thing
you've ever been in your life and you're
going to be standing here on the set of
what will be I think one of the greatest
television shows ever I never would have
believed it when did it start to set in
for you that like the game was really
picking up and becoming a phenomenon of
people where like the story of the game
not just the gameplay the story the game
was resonating with so many people those
are two different beats so the story hit
me when Ashley Johnson who played Ellie
in the game she and I first heard the
story and uh Neil druckman and Bruce
Rayleigh brought us in and said we want
to give you the same pitch that we that
we gave to Sony like this is how we got
to Green Light our game which is
interesting to hear you you look back at
it now and go well of course you would
make that game but at the time naughty
dog was made for or you know was known
for making games like
Uncharted it was like a really big
stretch for them they had done Crash
Bandicoot and jacket you know so it's
like that's not what they do and they
wanted to do this really really gritty
post-apocalyptic horror game
um that was about a love story and it's
like that's not what we do
um so we sat down with them and they
walked us through and it was about an
hour long
and they just beat by beat and they
could see where it's like we're gonna
fill this in and we're gonna figure out
how we get here but they had the entire
story laid out Soup To Nuts from the
very beginning to the very end even to
the last scene
and by the time I smoked and they were
like you want guys to take a break he's
like yeah yeah
take a break and Ash and I walked
outside and I lit a cigarette and we
just kind of both stared off blankly
into the mid distance and I just said
do you realize that if this thing sucks
it's because of us like we are the
weakest link clearly and we were just
overwhelmed because
as a gamer myself too nobody was telling
these stories in games and for multiple
reasons it's not that
nobody wanted to it's that either the
landscape wasn't available for it the
ground wasn't ripe for it the technology
didn't exist to support it the talent
within the writing and and the directing
wasn't there because that's not where
the focus was that's not what Gamers
thought that they wanted and true to
form people don't know what they want
until you give it to them
but when it was something that was
phenomenal
I still love whenever someone brings up
the uh like someone gives me something
to sign if it's the first copy like the
first run of those games you'll see a
sticker on the system the makers of
Uncharted which was even Sony going see
we did good things you'll like this one
too
um but then all of a sudden it sells
crazy and it's getting all of the awards
and it's it's blowing people's minds and
it becomes this this social event it
becomes this cultural phenomenon as you
said
um that's when I knew that we had done
something that was way bigger than us
way bigger than a game and here we are
10 years later
and the stories that people have told me
um
whether they be teenagers
whether it's now people who were too
young to play the game when it first
came out but now they've played the game
and
um
people who have reconnected with their
parents people who have healed their
relationship with their father or their
daughter
has been one of the greatest I think
byproducts of this story
and to think that now that is going to
proliferate to a whole group of people
who didn't have a PlayStation who
wouldn't ever pick up a controller
and are now watching this every Sunday
night and crying all the tears that
we've been doing for the last 10 years
is just
like you said it's phenomenal there's
been various conversations I think about
this the last of us being adapted to
movies the shows through the decades
since the game came out did you ever
have conversations with Neil or the team
about you playing the character in live
action
yeah I mean there's the conversations
are always popping up yeah and the thing
that I really respect about Neil is he
was always focused he's still to this
day he's always focused on the thing
that is in front of him and there's the
tertiary conversation of what does this
look like if we do this and and maybe I
could do this but
even when we were shooting the first
game it was well we got to set the
separate franchise come on let's let's
squeeze this out for three games
and he goes I have to act like this is
the only game we're going to make and
it's like people are going to be pissed
with this ending dude they're gonna
they're gonna Riot with this ending and
he goes good
I just don't want them to be ambivalent
they hate it fine they love it great
but if they don't care that means we
didn't do our job so he's always been
focused on the story that he's telling
the one that's in front of him but when
it came to I mean Neil's really kind of
like who would you want to play Joel and
I mean I bounced around
um I remember we were talking about
um airport lounges uh I've met Josh
Brolin a handful of times and the last
time I saw him was that LAX I was like
hey man I don't know if you remember
this or not you and I met in New Mexico
brief I was like I do I do I said there
may come a script across your desk and
and before you either dismiss it either
way just give it a look I really think
that you benefit from playing this
character at either the character would
benefit from it being played by you he's
like give a look what's it called it's
like it's called The Last of Us and it's
a feature film right now that's being
developed he's like okay I'll take a
look
and what's funny is is that I think Josh
Brolin would have been a great choice I
think that there's you look at the
character especially in the game you go
yeah that Maps 100 that Josh Brolin
playing that short
but what I love is when you get someone
like Craig Mason involved and these
conversations between he and you'll drop
and go back and forth that goes what
happens if we shake it up a little bit
and who do we get that can not only have
bring something new to it and something
fresh to it
but also
kind of change the character a little
bit we have an opportunity to do things
differently here and the second that
Neil said I think we got Pedro Pascal I
went
oh oh my God that's perfect
it's perfect because first of all
he's
an incredibly talented actor and
secondly everybody loves him so
people are gonna be like what he's our
daddy yeah
everything on Tick Tock is Pedro past
and I can tell you this that man I
there's some people who are like oh
please be nice you know just please be
nice and I love our first meeting we
were up in Calgary and I was having
dinner and he passed behind me and we
kind of way through the window and he
came back inside and stood there
awkwardly and it's like what are we
doing here man are we Spider-Man yeah I
was like yeah I was like you be and I
was like come here dude and we just gave
a hug and I pulled him away and I was
like I have so many questions for you
and he goes I have none for you and I
was like oh we're gonna go along great
um he's been incredibly kind and
Incredibly gracious and what I love is
that he's not trying to ape anything
that we've done before we we did that we
shot it lit it scored it released it
everything it's it's already been done
for me
my goal and I've said this countless
times is I just wanted someone to show
me something different
what did I miss what was what was
underneath the floorboards or or what
rock did I not pick up and
it's it's a wonderful thing as an actor
because I've never had this experience
before and I I can't think of any other
actor that's had this experience where
it's like you had a kind of authorship
of something in a character you got to
see it put out
and now it's being done by a completely
different person but then you also get
to be involved in it
um calm Wilkinson who played uh Jean
Valjean in the original
Les Mis was you know he played that
character for I think 15 or 20 years and
then retired from it and then they
brought him back
not only to do this beautiful tribute to
the the musical and they lined up every
person that played Jean Valjean starting
with him and you could see the Echoes of
his performance in in every character
that it's done and somehow they are
standing on his shoulders so they have
to somehow emulate something that he did
but then also in the movie He plays the
priest that Jean Valjean steals the
candlestick's problem and it's just like
what a great way to contribute that's
the only example I could think of that I
got to do but you've talked about how
you think people are going to hate your
character coming up when you show up on
the show hopefully hopefully is it weird
to play a part after playing Joel which
has I mean the character of Joel gets
his own reactions but overall I think is
pretty beloved as a character you're
playing the opposite now sure what's it
like to kind of have to switch gears
within a similar Universe even though
it's a different medium that's the gig
man and that's something that I truly do
enjoy it is possible for an actor to
just view the world and view the story
from one lens and I'm one of those
people that subscribed to the theory
that there are no villains there's just
a hero from a different perspective I I
am 100 the hero of that story and I'm
living my movie of my own life and all
these other people are you know they
they are the they are the antithesis of
me and they they are the antagonist to
my protagonist
um so being able to find it's way more
interesting to me to find the empathy in
someone and try to understand their
perspective especially like that maps to
reality I think that you can't out hate
somebody
um and that's why empathy has to be the
key I have to find a way to number one I
have to be the problem because if you're
the problem I can't do anything about
you I can only do something about me but
if I could make myself the problem and
that makes it smaller a little bit more
manageable and then if I can find a way
to have empathy then it makes the world
easier to deal with
I do want to say I know we don't talk
spoilers for the game that haven't
happened on the show yet so I'm just
going to leave it at this I know how
this game ends I was team Joel the whole
time I'm just saying I know it might be
a controversial take I I was team Joel
that's team Joel does team Joel I get to
flip the script does team Joel mean team
decision oh yeah I was with this I I
think if I was in that position I I
don't know hopefully I never am but I've
been done September 29th
let's just somebody asked me is like
would you wait to turn if you were
bitten I was like you think I'd get
bitten yeah and 1201 I am a corpse there
is no me but you don't think the game
prepared I watched The Walking Dead for
10 years now I've played through the
last one so I feel like a little bit I'm
ready Walking Dead you're like if I have
a baseball bat and enough of a heads up
I can make 12 minutes
slower there's like plenty of allusions
to Joel having a dark past he's killed
people before he's done some things that
might put him on you know Joel sees
himself as a good guy because he's his
own protagonist but if you saw his
actions you might not know I love to
hear how much of Joel's like past that
we didn't see in the game that we don't
see in the show did you get to like
flesh out do you have a headcan enough
that you just worked out over the years
yes and it's a wonderful
um I think it's a wonderful exercise for
an actor to
come and come in with a backstory
everything should be motivated every
decision that you make as an actor
should be motivated by something so if
there's nothing there on the page that
you're finding that's motivating you
make something up and if it conflicts
with the character then that's the
director's responsibility to tell you
that
um
but there's a lot there was a shoot that
we did nobody knows about how about I
had trouble for saying this
um in between part one and part two
where we're just kind of testing out
some new tech and so just Neil and I
went down to a different stage than we
shot on down in in San Diego and he was
like I want to do a couple of scenes
from this because I don't really have
anything written so far but I have an
idea of the scene for this
are you comfortable just kind of running
a scene by yourself I was like sure and
so there's a scene and that we just kind
of made up on on the Fly about Joel
going into a bar
and so there are all of these
backstory moments that we get to find
out what happened where's Sarah's mom
um what happened to that relationship
what is the Schism between he and Tommy
and the thing that I love about the show
is
whereas in the game the story is
fundamental and it is foundational to
the experience but at the end of the day
it is a game we need to do things that
prompt the player and pull the player
forward in the game and the use of story
as a mechanic for that is is perfect
but a show
first of all we're controlling where
you're looking the entire time so we
have the opportunity to go look over
here for a second if we if we put the
camera over here we promise you that
we'll make it compelling like we're
going to slow down and take you
to a 20-year time lapse between Bill and
Frank a character relationship you
didn't think you cared anything about
but now it's the number you'll never
look at strawberries the same way again
this is what the show has the ability to
do and
that also says well let's take a look at
Joel's backstory and let's let's learn
more about that and that is there's a
beautiful thing that happens as you see
now would you be interested in exploring
that more of that backstory like if they
did a prequel
season or maybe a prequel game The Last
of Us Part zero yes look one of the
things that I think is
um
evidence that this is Art I think true
art inspires other art and it inspires
artists
um there are so many people that picked
up the oboe because they heard you know
that cue that John Williams wrote for
Star Wars when two sons were setting
they're like I want to play that
instrument so I think that's art is when
um how many people you know started
putting a chisel to Marble after they
saw the David it's like that is Art and
I do put the last of us the story
because I've seen the evidence of it
I've seen people go I've written my
college thesis on this or I'm now in
games I'm now working at naughty dog
because of this game half of the people
that work on eye doctor because they're
they're because of The Last of Us people
that were in working on the show because
of the last of us there's just this this
byproduct again that happens when people
get inspired by something they moved by
something that they want to be a part of
making something and so a lot of people
have approached me like hey this is a
non-canonical story that I was inspired
to write because of the last of us would
you want to be a part of it
my whole thing is this and people always
ask is there going to be The Last of Us
Part three I have no idea no idea I
didn't know it was gonna be a part two
there he goes but if Neil has a story
that he wants to tell
um and he wants me to be a part of it
anyway I am there
seven days a week and twice on Sunday I
I I absolutely would follow him and I
have a followed him to the gates of
Helen Back bought ice cream
um I love your little isms that's the
Texas boy in me coming out which is
actually
I don't even remember I don't remember
there being anything in the audition
sides maybe Neil could correct on this
that said Joel was from Texas
it was just when I looked at that
character I walked in and boy if you can
Google it
it's not my jeans reflected light it was
not good this was like
2008 2009 audition time yeah so like Ed
Hardy was still mildly acceptable on
some social levels
um and if they were sold out you had
Affliction it was not good there was
just there was a lot of writing on all
of my clothes and I had this Final
Fantasy haircut and I walked in
and Neil's like I was I was so angry
that my I was a huge fan of Uncharted I
was a huge fan of naughty dog and my
agents like I got you an audition for
Naughty Dog I was like nailing it
awesome what's it for and she goes I'm
sending the audition sites through right
now and I was driving down to go have
Thanksgiving dinner with a friend of
mine and I was like I
I'm so angry with you right now because
I'm so not right for this role so so not
right for this
but I show up
and I walk in this is the Sound Stage on
Culver Studios
um that's I mean historic lot and the
Sound Stage there was an office right
next to it that's where they were
holding auditions and they would walk
you into the Sound Stage and there's
where you do the thing and I walk in and
I look around the room and in every
chair in the waiting room with some
version of the guy on the page
and I'm like
I'm I can't do this I've instantly got
filled with fear doubt everything and
there's a sign-in sheet and go and you
sign your name and they look to see okay
so we're ready for you
and I was like
I haven't signed in yet I can leave and
nobody would know nobody would know and
I literally put my hand on the door and
I twist the knob and I'm turning to go
and the casting director goes Troy I
went
yeah she goes they're ready for you
I like guys just get in the door just
let's go it works and you were that
close to not being Joel yeah
that close and I I think about that
moment a lot
um
because again this thing has changed my
life and not only that but I would I
would still be watching it I would still
be playing it but I would definitely be
on the outside and not where I am right
now
foreign